dre vous demandez quel bilan vous faites
depuis l'adoption du pacs puis du
mariage homosexuel moi je constate que
le sol ne s'est pas ouvert sous nos
pieds que la terre n'est pas sorti du
système solaire que voilà nous
continuons à vivre normal or vous et vos
frères et soeurs de penser nous avez
vous nous annonciez une catastrophe une
apocalypse le monde ne serait jamais
plus comme avant
voyez que tout se passe pas trop mal
quand vous étiez là quand le
gouvernement qui a promu ces différentes
a notamment la loi taubira a promis que
jamais on irait sur la pma et le
gouvernement actuel promet que jamais on
ira sur la gpa donc je pense qu on peut
nous reconnaître en tout cas de ne pas
avoir été naïf sur les conséquences de
ces différentes lois qui aboutissent
effectivement à nos yeux non pas à une
satellisation de la lune est déjà
satellite de la terre et métaux a
effectivement une déstructuration du
repère qui nous tient énormément à coeur
normand de français le père à la place
du père souvent manquant ya pas de père
parfait et je ne suis pas un père
parfait mais l'idée que l'on conçoive
délibérément des enfants en les privant
de toute référence paternelle pas quand
ça arrive dans la cité il ya des
accidents des difficultés des drames des
deuils aussi on vit en aide à ces
familles notamment famille dit mono
parentales l'état s'engage et nous
sommes engagés nous mêmes alliances vita
auprès de ces familles mais créé de
toutes pièces comme un enfant qui n'aura
pas de pair qui sera privé de la moitié
de son origine biologique généalogique
nous trouvons ça profondément juste pour
l'enfant les doctrines de base et
solidaire des plus fragiles pour nous le
plus fragile si l'enfant alors on peut
entendre tous les désirs possible on
attend énormément et moi j'aime beaucoup
de désir que par parfois je jeu
restreint par respect pour les plus
fragiles et bien l'enfant pour nous est
le plus fragile dont celle où il entend
contester dans la primaire pma pour tout
j'ai beaucoup de mal avec un peu de ma
pour tout pma pour tout c'est le sort
fait à l'enfant c'est ça votre
principale critique simplement que pour
nous un enfant
les français pour cet homme vous allez
remarquer dans les sondages la façon
dont les français doit être
contradictoire quand on leur propose un
nouveau droit pour quelqu'un ils vont
dire oui généreusement mais quand on
leur parle de l'enfant à caudiès qu'un
enfant vous considérez comme dans une
pma il doit avoir droit à son père et à
sa mère
ils sont très majoritairement a dit ils
sont à 61 % à dire oui voyez donc c'est
se placer du côté des enfants pour nous
c'est un peu le devoir de la société ils
ne votent pas il n'a pas de voix
on peut pas lui demander son avis c'est
vrai mais prendre le risque de le priver
d'un père alors même que voyez le
gouvernement macron vient de de proposer
au nom des 1000 premiers jours de
l'enfant de renforcer le congé paternel
on à boris urrugne et que nous explique
que le père est essentiel dans les
premiers jours et dans le même temps on
va escamoter le père on va dire à des
enfants le père est allé vous avez un
peu esquiver une partie de ma question
de toute manière vous étiez opposé au
mariage homosexuel indépendamment de
toute autre suggestion nous l'étions
pour cette raison précise
qui était il n'y a pas de mariage sans
sans filiation sans procréation est
inéluctablement cela privé des enfants
de leur père et c'est la raison pour
laquelle c'est au nom de l'enfant me
reprenne nos pancartes de l'époque son
nom de l'enfant et l'avenir nous a donné
raison il ya dire libération l'a dit il
avait raison on s'est bien moqué d'eux
mais il avait finalement raison c'est il
ne l'avait pas de naïveté et
l'enchaînement des lois mais on parlera
tout à l'heure de la gpa qui est un qui
est un dossier distinct alors comme vous
le remarquez vous êtes en net
oui j'ai minorité il y a des pourris 1/2
pour et la parole et à raquel garrido
qui est franchement pour la pma pour
toutes oui moi je voudrais quand même
dire à notre invité que pour moi se
poser des questions sur ces thématiques
c'est pas être fasciste je trouve que
c'est pas plus mal qu'en france on est
un système autour du concept de
bioéthique ou voilà une tonne de temps
en temps au bout de quelques années on
remet sur la table la comptable des
compatibilité entre les avancées
scientifiques et nos intentions sur nous
on va où on en est la société est ce
qu'on a envie de faire
voilà et et je pense que c'est jeu
comment dire je veux vous donner acte de
votre bonne foi dans votre dans votre
pensée dans vos intentions voilà je ne
suis quand même pas du tout d'accord
avec vous parce que je pense qu'il ya
une contradiction très forte dans votre
façon de voir la famille c'est que vous
dites que le père c'est une chose et
vous parlez de côté d'eux des gènes et
vous semblez fusionner ces deux notions
de génétique et de paternité
or c'est pas du tout la conception
française de la paternité nous avons en
france et c'est absolument sublime une
conception absolument civique de la
paternité c'est pour ça qu'on reconnaît
par exemple
adoption plénière dans plein de pays du
monde ont plein de pays du monde quand
on adopte l'adoption n'est pas dite
plénière c'est pas parce qu'on considère
qu effectivement il ne peut y avoir que
la génétique qui fait 7 la paternité
total en france non nous on est le pays
de la révolution française on est pays
de la politique qui ont dit mme la
personne qui s'occupe de l'enfant et le
père et on a même un système de mariage
qui au fond désigne comme père qui le
mari de la dame qui a accouché et on
s'en fiche complètement de savoir si
c'est vraiment voulu ou pas le vrai père
la loi française dans le code civil
français est très clair là dessus on
s'en fiche complètement des gènes et
c'est là où je trouve que vous êtes en
contradiction avec notre culture
française qui estime qu'au fond l'enfant
il a le droit à des parents et on a le
droit d'être dans un projet parental
positif à son égard mais pour moi ça ça
n'a rien à voir avec une espèce de
purger les régions génétiques
michel hervieu réponses sur ce premier
point en ce qui concerne déjà je pense
qu'on pourrait trouver un terrain commun
sur une ou un autre point qui est la
marchandisation du corps et notamment
des gamètes
moi je suis assez étonné de voir que
l'on s'engouffre dans le marché de la
procréation qui est capitalistique
il ya des profits considérables et voilà
que les les gamètes les l'utérus des
femmes etc sont utilisés comme soit des
produits se vendent comme des machines
et j'aimerais bien moi que les
féministes s'engage pour lutter contre
l'instrumentation du corps de la femme
dans ce genre de procédés parce que à
partir du moment où ça se passe de
manière médicale à partir du moment où
une femme qui n'a pas de problèmes
d'infertilité recours à des techniques
médicales pour progrès alors que la
médecine est réservé en allemand à cela
et bien on entre dans une logique de
marché alors assez vous savez qu'en
france la loi interdit de vendre ces
homos c'est comme ça que ça se voit moi
j'ai des commandes par exemple ou pas à
vous pour vous parler à une donneuse
oui moi quand j'ai eu mon premier enfant
à 24 ans et entre mon premier et mon
deuxième enfant j'ai donné des ovocytes
dans le régime français c'est-à-dire
anonymement
je n'ai jamais su je n'ai jamais su à
qui tient plus anonyme d'une part et
d'autre part vous le voyez en belgique
où c'est gratuit il importe 80% du
sperme delà du danemark
donc on entonne un tournant très longue
passe
une jurée de donno faire des campagnes
on attire les camps bascule la loi est
en train de lever l'anonymat des dons de
gamètes parce que les jeunes qui sont
nés de dons anonymes de gamètes ont
protesté et on dit ce n'est pas normal
qu'on nous ait privé de la moitié notre
patrimoine génétique parce qu'ils
veulent savoir d'où ils viennent mais je
n'ai pas répondu à votre à votre
remarque légitime bien sûr sur
l'adoption l'adoption vient en france
réparer un deuil un drame subi par un
enfant il était en deuil et il a été sa
mère n'a pas pu l'accueillir où ses
parents et on lui qu'on le confie à une
famille ce n'est pas fait pour la
famille c'est fait pour l'enfant we
dance dans le cas d adoption
effectivement nous estimons avec
beaucoup de français qu'il est
préférable que l'enfant puisse être
confiée à une famille qui a un père et
une mère parce que terre et mer sont
complémentaires ils ne sont pas un père
vous êtes dans un jugement de morale
piano et aux jugements moraux façon de
se mettre en ménage ne l'est vraiment là
vous dites l'homosexualité comme façon
de vivre vous vous la lisez comme la
filière chars définition contraire à
l'intérêt de l'enfant ce qui est faux
puisque la t on à des études c'est vrai
qu'on tente longtemps les gens ont été
plutôt méfiants vis-à-vis de la
parentalité homosexuels et je le dis
sans ambages je trouve ça normal que les
gens se posent des questions ils se
disent est ce que c'est vraiment
l'intérêt de l'enfant
mais on a tellement de reculer notamment
des reculs d'études internationales qui
montre non non viables étude combinée
des fours à bien quoi mais la question
c'est leur père mersenne robert les
enfants vous l'avez vu vous avez vu cet
homme qui était né d'indian américain il
a cherché pendant 50 ans son père d'où
il venait
on ne fait pas un enfant avec deux
nouveaux sites